OK, we have now learned that what we
suspected is happening. Former White
House press secretary under Donald Trump,
Sarah Huckabee. Sanders will be running
for governor of Arkansas in 2022. She will
be first needing to win the Republican
primary in twenty twenty two. Sarah Huckabee.
Sanders is 38. She was a completely unabashed,
dishonest promulgates and defender of Trump's
lies. And it would be terrible for the country
and for Arkansas for her to be the next governor,
but she really does have a shot at it. Her father,
of course, former Arkansas Governor Mike
Huckabee, her family well known in Arkansas.
I think it's quite plausible that she could win
the Republican primary and subsequently become the
governor of Arkansas. Now what I find more there's
a couple of things I find interesting about this.
No. One is that she apparently has been endorsed
by Donald Trump. There's a real question as to
whether that's helpful. And right now, with a lot
of the Republican electorate still being very pro
Trump, it might seem as though it would be helpful
in June of twenty twenty two as we get closer, as
in the primary, as we get closer to November of
twenty twenty two, it is an open question whether
a Trump endorsement or a Trump administration
association will be helpful or not. Now,
under the same umbrella, there are questions as
to whether Trump's daughter in law, Laura Trump,
will run for Senator of North Carolina. Will
Ivanka run for something? Will Don Junior
run for something or other? Trump's going to
look at trying to be president in the future.
And the next two years are going to be people keep
calling in and asking what happens to Trump is
what happens to the Trump movement. And my answer
has been, we don't know. What we need to track is,
number one, do these Trumpy and members
of Congress like. Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Lauren Bobert and Madison Cawthorn, do
they get reelected in 2022, that will
be a signal as to whether these are sort of
one hit wonders, one term wonders that rode
on Trump ism in 2020. And it's not going to get
them any further. But if they get reelected, that
would be a real signal if Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
with the alleged endorsement of Donald Trump,
wins the Republican gubernatorial primary in
2022 and becomes governor, that would be a sign
that Trump ism has some staying power, but we
just don't know yet. And it's too early to say.
We we I don't even know that it makes sense to
say more because we just have to wait and see.
Now, one quick thing. I played this clip earlier
in another context of Joe Biden's White House
press secretary, Jen Psaki was asked, what
is Joe Biden's position on Trump endorsing
Sarah Huckabee Sanders in the 2022 Republican
Arkansas gubernatorial primary. Yesterday,
former President Trump endorsed Sarah Huckabee,
Sanders for governor of Arkansas in 2022.
Where is President Biden's stand on that
particular race and how high is
this on his list of priorities?
Well, how high is the Arkansas Republican
gubernatorial primary on the president's
list of priorities? Not high. I can
confirm for you, I'm not running for
governor of Connecticut in the future, so
I'm here to confirm that for you as well.
Yeah. So a very low priority right now for Joe
Biden. As you can imagine, Trump's endorsement
within the Arkansas Republican primary for an
election two years away. And for whatever reason,
that that clip really tickles me. No,
it's not very high on Joe Biden's list.
We're going to follow all of this and see what is
the long term impact, if any, of Trump in politics
on the House, Senate and governor's
races in the next and upcoming elections?